in the 90s you toured with Neil Young I
think he's like one of the great we've
talked about Neil Young You toured with
him and that had to be intimidating
because you had to open for his audience
right yeah and did that blow your mind
because uh he's iconic and his audience
knows his music that would be like like
really scary yeah Bob Dylan too he took
Dylan took me out on the road when my
record was out for a year and it was
failing so I had this huge signing you
know thing and then I did nothing I told
me 3 000 records in a year was that a
nightmare for you well because I mean
here they had made a fuss you finally
get your record deal and you probably
like of course I'm gonna sell millions
of Records no I knew I knew I was a folk
singer like in the height of grunge you
know like my and I was playing solo
acoustic in front of you know Bauhaus
and the Ramones and like this weird
Gothic grunge Revival and you know there
was no place for you on radio yeah there
was a zero place for me and so I really
had to be a fighter and a strapper and I
did you know 40 cities every 30 days and
I did six shows a day and I was touring
my little guts out and then Dylan took
me on the road and he believed in me
Dylan and Neil Young were more like
mentors to you they were and Dylan went
over my lyrics with me every night and
gave me books to read and music to
listen to and he liked what I did he
really believed in me when you have
Dylan believe in you and nobody else
you're kind of like I'm okay and then I
could take off then if uh Dylan like
like here you were you'd only sold 3 000
records and so oh you went in the studio
made another record and then that's what
happened well um well I went in to make
another record after I toured with Dylan
and I started kind of really changing
myself to try and get on the radio
um and then Neil wanted to take me out
and so I quit making that record I went
out with Neil and Neil's like don't do
it he's like just stick to what you do
don't change don't change a thing for
radio and that real punk rock attitude
of just like screw it all do what you do
and well he's the master of that he is
and then you're meant for me to start
taking off a radio and then you know I
went from selling 3000 records in a year
to selling 500 000 records wow every
month wow
thank you